[Music]
you guys know how diamonds
are women's best friends really well
that's like what marketing wants to make
you believe right
well anyway so they're common well
diamonds the way they're made
is like when is carbon is being crushed
and heated
far beneath the earth's surface over
billions of years
which is the reason why they're so
coveted because they're just
it's like a crazy-ass process in order
to even create them and it takes
long-ass time and it's intense heat
there are lab-grown diamonds too and
once again it takes like a lot of
pressure a lot of heat a lot of
[ __ ] going on but recently these
researchers said that they were able to
create
two types of structurally distinct
diamonds and one that's like typically
worn in jewelry and the other
type called lons lonsdale light
lonzolite which is found naturally
at the site of meteorite impacts and is
harder than most diamonds so these
they're able to create these two
diamonds it comes from outer space in
room temperature
huh what the [ __ ] why that's great take
some time
like you'd grow your crystals you know
those crystal projects
uh you got blue ones pink ones yellow
ones yeah
how do they do it in room temperature
that's crazy i could make one
you just put salt inside of uh sugar
uh boiling water and then you let it
evaporate
and you got diamonds right there well
here they're saying that they're
they're able to do it in just a matter
of minutes
and at room temperature to create these
diamonds oh what temperature is it
normally made in
uh uh it does tell me are they vs1
clarity yeah what's the clarity so it
says natural diamonds are usually formed
over billions of years
about 93 miles deep in the earth where
there are high pressures and
temperatures above 1000 degrees
celsius so it's like 1832 degrees
fahrenheit
wow um but here 1000 degrees
yeah well researchers were able to
discover like the way they're able to do
this
is um they're able to
have a twisting sliding force
into these materials and
they are applying pressure to create
this twisting or sliding force
and they're saying that that is what's
causing the carbon atoms to move into
place
are they making fun of god like that's a
way easier way dude
billions of years look at me i twist and
turn it
that's crazy i wonder if we can make
gold they spent the
time and energy on the wrong stones no
fool's gold is
a thing but it's just not good yeah well
it's it does does it have like the same
electric uh current oh who's gold is
pyrite or some [ __ ] that's pyrite
it's for fools is this gonna like
make the value of diamonds go way down
or what um pop doesn't get girls wet the
way the other one's
true this is very true like the value of
diamonds is already controlled anyway by
the beers
because it's the beers the beard
it's in about
the beers family whoa that's crazy did
you know that if they step foot on
american soil they go to jail
really who's that monopoly oh those guys
the diamond guys
what country are they in i don't know i
heard this fib
oh huh it's a rumor okay
i don't know i can't i can't say it's
[ __ ] i just heard but that is crazy
though that they found a way easier way
to do it that doesn't take
billions of years and a thousand degrees
do they look the same
well and it's just as hard can you tell
them it's harder it's harder so you
could make a better diamond saw with
these
wow yeah exactly and no imperfections
right and
well i don't know about all that harder
diamond means you can [ __ ] do the
mission impossible open the glass with
it i always wanted one of those
and then you get the and then it's a
circle yeah you get the plumber's thing
yeah
you can pop it off yeah and you come
down on the wires and you
almost hit the ground yeah and then and
then your sweat drops and that like
ruins all the
exactly like that yep no but yeah so
this is what it looks like under a
microscope so
and then you join the church of
scientology yeah yeah yeah yeah mary
mary and you jump on some couch on
the meteorite one that i told you about
and then this is a river of diamonds
and like they're just like
microscopically like they're just
they found that they're able to create
it now they just gotta work on it to
make it like bigger
crazy and so they said that they the
amount of pressure
it's really interesting they said that
it is
the pressure is it more than peer
pressure no
so it says nothing is damn you actually
just gave me a cool like has anyone ever
done that metaphor where it's like you
go through so much pressure and then
like you get a diamond out of it yeah
yeah yeah
pressure makes diamonds you do oh okay
cool all right then i won't put it in a
thing
tim's quote make sure you you go through
pressure in life
because at the end you become a diamond
no because you're a diamond girl
you get a diamond girl you because
you'll become a diamond girl
oh and you're a dime girl mom there's
something there
you're diamond did you know that you're
not
you're not just diamond quality your
lungs delight quality
that is better that's stronger it's
really good
lawns delight yeah so anyway the the
high pressure is equivalent to 640
african elephants balancing on the tip
of a belly shoe what's never measured
why do they have to be african elements
elephants yeah it can't be thai
no african elephants maybe they're
they're they're bigger
that's what i just said oh maybe thai
elephants are smaller
yeah maybe okay there's a lot of
elephants in southeast asia
thai people love elephants though it's
like our symbol of life i always see it
in the aluminum
rice holders that you guys have yeah
republicans like elephants too
that's true true that's true um
yeah the white elephant is like a symbol
in thailand of like um
christmas gifts that was funny
i'm some [ __ ] there's actual white
elephants yeah wait why aren't they just
albino why was that funny is it like a
guy because
white elephant exchange yeah yeah yeah
steve she's so stupid
i was like they were asking a bunch of
questions
but why elephants i mean i don't think
they're actually like are they sacred
it's some it's a symbol of cow in hindu
rarity
look it up please thai white elephant
there used to be tigers in japan i think
until they ate them all
for reals they ate them did they mm-hmm
yeah sure no i made that up i don't know
in thailand white elephants royal power
sacred and our symbol of royal power
yeah does the thai
king have a white elephant because it
says all those discovered are presented
to the king although this presentation
is usually a ceremonial one the
elephants are not actually taken into
captivity so then they bring it to the
king and the king goes
it's white and then they
and it takes a fat [ __ ] on the floor a
white [ __ ] too
all they do for real no damn it like
bats
guano yeah we all know that yeah yeah
cause a century
too it's classic pink elephants oh are
they because they're pink too
pink looking mm-hmm oh [ __ ] do they
actually have one
like in the in the flesh i want to see
one oh like not a statue
wait wait do they actually exist or they
don't i don't know of course they do you
don't know about pink elf
it sounds like ecstasy sounds like
[ __ ] dumbo's uh
[ __ ] mirage of a dream yeah that's
scary
wait what happened i used to fast
forward that
the music and all that [ __ ] so scary
yeah yeah when i was like three
dude i recently watched dumbo again it's
[ __ ] sad
it's satisfying sad story i couldn't
comprehend that before i was like so
that's 101 dalmatians
every single [ __ ] movie actually is
pretty sexy isn't it they're all really
sad they don't have happy endings
i haven't seen you no they do they have
happy endings but they're just sad
moments
yeah sad journeys remember that like
really
creepy part of like when you're on
splash mountain and everything
goes like gets really scary as you're
going up the the last drop
yeah the music gets crazy and it's all
like the vultures and [ __ ] that shit's
cool
i don't remember this donor
i just like to do funny faces while we
go down to splash mountains
yeah have you seen those guys that like
they go all out like there's one where
they're
like with the playstation controllers
i've seen ones where they have a fake
table with like like fake
food on it and they're like acting like
they're yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but if
you throw up a west side or something
they won't let you have the picture
is that right they want to avoid all
like gang signs if you like flash your
tits they they don't show the picture
yeah nothing that could be like you know
apparently this is a white elephant
oh that's a light that's [ __ ] i
guess it's a pink elephant
it looks like testicle yeah that's how
elephant's skin looks like
it's like yeah you just took a hot bath
or something and the blood's just rushed
into it yeah oh it says white elephant
gift exchange origin let's find out
came from thailand thai people just hate
buying personal presents for people one
theory is at the white elephant gift
exchange dates back
several centuries to the legend of the
king of siam which is thailand oh [ __ ]
according to legend
to the king would give rare albino
elephants to people in his court he was
displeased with
oh it was it was hoped the people would
be ruined by the cost of the animals is
upkeep clearly the white elephant
exchange was not intended for good times
oh it's like oprah giving away cars and
then you got to pay registration and now
you're
sorry damn so he would financially
ruin people in his court like man you
annoying bro like
hey i'm gonna give you this you're wired
out and they're like yeah
and they're like oh [ __ ] i gotta pay the
bill he's like oh i can't pay for my
kids braces i gotta take this [ __ ]
elephant dude think about winning a
horse
if you if you want a horse you're like
oh [ __ ] right
that's an instant oh [ __ ] that's true
take care of a horse
and then the craziest thing too is that
they're actually quite affordable to
purchase but very expensive to upkeep
horses or white elephants horses i have
a friend with horse it's [ __ ] crazy
really they have it do they have like a
separate stable they have it in their
own house they have they have they live
in like farmland and they have a stable
for it
but she's a horse person for sure if you
ever met her you're like oh yeah you're
a horse person
what's a horse person they just can't
stop talking about horses all day no
they just have a vibe to them that like
they probably had a lot of horse art
growing up and like uh
they have hair that goes like past their
back oh my god hello
yeah that's exactly what you mean yeah
yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
anyway back to diamonds here oh
yeah how was diamond shopping for you i
actually
um you mean when i bought the engagement
ring um chia actually like
you know cause i didn't realize how
complex the whole process is and how
many different types and like cuts and
[ __ ]
s2 vs one clarity yeah all that [ __ ]
right i didn't know about any of that so
chia
was like so here's what she did i think
i've talked about this before um
years before we even like i like
proposed you know i'm saying she was
like hey just so you know
um like her friend was in town one time
and she's like i'm gonna get my hair
done with my friend can i like borrow
the car
i was like okay i should do your thing
and then that night she's like okay babe
i have a confession
i actually didn't go get my well they
did get their hair done but she's like
what we also did is i found this jeweler
that everybody still looked like [ __ ] so
you're like you didn't get your hair
done yeah i was like what what is this
mess
but she was like uh i found there's a
jeweler that i really like
and um no pressure at all but like i
talked to this person
and whenever you're ready they know
exactly what kind of like cut i like
what like what style what style of ring
i might like so
they know who you are when you're ready
you can go talk to this person and
they'll be like oh okay oh you're chia's
fiance you guys already had this talk
you're gonna get married so you guys
yeah yeah so it's not weird yeah and we
you know we've already been talking
like long distance [ __ ] is like we're
okay we're either in this [ __ ] for the
long run or like why the [ __ ] are we
doing this right
yeah was it a relief for you to know
that she kind of
pre-planned yeah totally because i was
like now like you know because you're
paying so much for a ring you feel like
i
don't want to get the wrong thing so she
kind of took all that pressure off of me
oh that's so true and i could and i
would still i and she left a few
decisions left for me to kind of make
that's good i need that
i need that yeah i was gonna say i was
like does it suck the fun out yes
like the adventure of it it wasn't like
i was just going in and paying for it
you know what i'm saying it was like
okay so here's what i basically like and
then i was also able to still make a few
small decisions
cool so it's easy that's cool so you
went to a specific jeweler that was in
la like she already
that's who she was a fan of already yes
jean dusso
uh tv johnny you do say jean ducey tv
johnny
and uh and you got grills on the side
that'd be tight johnny johnny dang
johnny
i went to k jewelers every kiss begins
with
k it worked on me that branding
[Music]
you